how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have a really big treat today as the
new Captain America of the MCU has been
revealed and it is not Sam Wilson aka
Falcon now when we left off at the end
of Avengers endgame Steve Rogers gave
the shield to Sam
there for passing down the mantle of
Captain America to Sam however we have
leaked photos from the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier and we see a new Captain
America who is not Sam but is in fact
John Walker better known as US agent as
you can see here he is wearing a full
Captain America uniform complete with
the helmet and the shield now I know
this may be very confusing for some
people as to why Sam is not the new
Captain America so let me explain what
is happening here this is kind of
following what they did in the comics in
the comics when they needed a new
Captain America and Sam Wilson was up
for the mantle he would ultimately get
denied because the government didn't
think it was the right time for him and
they're going the same route here
because remember Captain America was
originally a soldier it became a
government position almost so what's
happening here is that the government is
not letting Sam be Captain America and
there's a pretty simple and easy
explanation for this Sam did not sign
the sokovia accords he was a wanted
criminal
not just to America but the world yes he
did hope in saving the world from Thanos
but before Avengers in game and after
Captain America Civil War he was on the
run from the government because he was a
wanted man so the government steps in
takes the shield away and says you can't
be Captain America despite saving the
world most of the world thinks you're a
wanted fugitive and we can't have a
former fugitive who was wanted by the
United Nations be Captain America the
symbol of America and Bucky is in the
exact same boat so he can't be Captain
America either so they give the shield
and the mantle of Captain America to
u.s. agent John Walker and that's what
we see here actor Wyatt Russell as John
Walker in full Captain America uniform
now of course by the end of the show
something is going to happen like John
Walker's actually a villain Falcon and
Bucky have to stop him and after they
stop him they finally allow Falcon to
become the true Captain America after
Steve Rogers so for those of you upset
don't worry Sam will eventually become
Captain America u.s. agent is only
Captain America for a time but I must
say the outfit does look really good
they even have the helmet
and of course we'll see him in full
action when we finally get the release
of the Falcon in the Winter Soldier
series for Disney Plus later on this
year in the meantime let me know what
you think about this outfit and the new
Captain America John Walker let me know
in the comments and also don't forget to
like the video and subscribe with
notifications turned on to enter my
giveaway for a chance to win Xbox one or
ps4 I'm picking a winner at five hundred
and fifty thousand subscribers as always
thank you all so much for watching we'll
fluff